you push horror into a different
direction you you weavin in with fairy
tales with dark fairy tales with dark
fantasy but do you think that there is
some relationship I'm just asking I have
no idea it's some relationship between
the the horror film and what you can do
with it almost like an experimental film
say you can push the envelope of the
medium a little further
oh and there's people look the best
horror film maker of all times probably
is David Lynch yeah you know and I think
it's because his logic is the logic of
dreams now I think that any genre has a
breadth and a width that you need to
accept an explorer and you land on the
range is like you're like a singer you
know you may admire somebody else's
singing but you know your range you know
your what note you can reach and you try
to be really good in that range and stay
comfortable and make it your own and
enjoy it not try to supplant it you know
and I think Lynch sings in a different
range yeah completely always no matter
what he touches and I think that that is
his niche that is his voice and and and
he makes every song unique but III think
that of course you can Dre ur was doing
it with one tear yes and in a strange
way that amazing movie haxon was doing
its own in a very different way you know
so yes horror has when people talk about
horror with some disdain I actually find
it interesting because every genre is
like that there was the other sturgeon
law 90% of everything is [ __ ] you know
to that I oppose my own law which is the
belt or alone ten percent of everything
is really good you know itself I try to
go to the ten percent but but horror
particularly gets it this bad by but in
comedy you can laugh like or not afford
comedy or Woody Allen right and they're
they're the same genre but the spectrum
is in two different sides and and the
latitude of horror often is ignored and
and some of the most poignant political
films of every and
you know them you know the usual
suspects are in horror Texas Chainsaw
Massacre Night of the Living Dead these
are true freaks you know these are truly
contesting the films that are contesting
the status school and that everything is
alright you know whereas Miller many
Miller dramas and comedies that pass for
good are actually telling you everything
everything's fine and you're gonna come
out of this ok so they don't have that
caustic element that horror has in its
nature